welcome back i got too excited and i
went like 20 seconds over time i hope
youtube still lets me publish this video
i'll try my best but what i was saying
is is um how how how related these two
formulas are and that makes sense
because at this point the ball is
stationary and it's completely the same
as a ball just being dropped you know a
stationary ball being dropped from
height h so we can use this formula to
do the same thing that we did
intuitively you know in the last video
so if we're just dropping a ball the
initial velocity is zero so this term
goes to zero so this term is the only
one that matters
and once again if we're dropping it we
start at height h and we go to zero so
the change in distance is now minus h
and a t squared over two well that
equals gravity
times what's the time the time is not
this full t naught it's t naught over
two right
so g
t naught
over two
squared over 2. you multiply both sides
times negative 1 and you get this exact
same thing
so that's pretty cool i i what i love
about physics is there's so many ways to
approach problems you can actually start
off with any one of the formulas that
that we've been we've been looking at
and as long as you you kind of keep
playing with it you keep thinking about
it you might not find the fastest route
to the solution but as long as you don't
do anything incorrect you will get the
solution so hopefully this gives you a
little bit of an intuition of projectile
motion in the next set of videos we're
going to make it slightly more
complicated but also slightly more
realistic and we're going to i'm going
to introduce you to what happens in
two-dimensional motion so when you you
know you're not throwing something
straight up you actually throw something
at an angle
like like you normally do
i'll i'll see you in in the next video